it was like a drive-by gossip session oh
my god well he'll must have frozen over
because Kim Kardashian invited Tristan
Thompson to dinner
[Music]
yeah like Kim the Kim who had this to
say about the NBA star after he
allegedly cheated on Chloe
with Kylie Jenner's former best friend
Jordan Woods what a loser
literally what a loser in a sneak peek
at the all-new season of Keeping Up with
the Kardashians the reality star calls
Coco to let her know that she invited
her baby daddy / ex to dinner like again
this is the girl who went full-blown
protective big sis on his when I see him
I'm going to like spit on him
so naturally Khloe was shook by Kim's
news you invited him to dinner I think
you gotta do what's best for you if you
want him to have a drink at the end
there's nothing wrong with that that's
beyond generous of you like crazy
generous yes but I gotta say Bravo Kim
for taking the high road I don't think
when Tristan was obviously right like
I'm obviously like that's not
[Music]
right
Chloe shares one-year-old true with
Tristan and the two seemed to be pretty
amicable beyond generous in December
Chloe hit up Twitter to update bans on
the status of her relationship with
Tristan writing quote we are
co-parenting so well right now it is a
great space to be in co-parenting is
such a hard space much respect to all
co-parent errs I think you just gotta
figure out really what's important to
you at the end of the day and when et
caught up with Chloe and her sister
Courtney's ex Scott Disick in June they
opened up about the hard work it takes
at the end of the day I mean you just
want to be happy you want to be content
you want to be comfortable life is a
challenge and if you work at what you
want you can get it but it takes hard
work simple as that you can easily live
less of a life without working as hard
and that's up to you so is Chloe ready
for a fresh new love when et sat down
with her in October she said she's not
really looking for all that she's just
focusing on her baby girl I'm just super
happy and content and I'm focused on
work and like taking care of me my body
and soul and true and I just I'm having
so much fun with her and what I want to
I will it's not some deliberate thing
that I think that hard about this is
what I love about the Kardashians they
go through all that drama
like I don't even know how to describe
it besides it's just so and eventually
forgive and keep it moving of course you
can count on et to bring you all the
latest on all that Kardashian drama so
make sure to keep it locked right here
until next time I'm Holly Stevens
[Music]